a long-awaited special guest is he
anywhere the man who needs no
introduction give you a very brief one
anyway and he is an alumni of the
Faculty of Arts and Social Sciences here
at the University and he's also
education and best about sharing his
passion for teaching and learning
especially at events like in Friday so
welcome to our live stream it's so great
to be here and what are you doing now so
when I was here in this illustrious
place actually I should say not exactly
this illustrious place this building
didn't exist when I was here and the
bridge over City Road took meant worth
building we're in a whole different
direction and my brain is confused
across so I did when I started here a
Bachelor of education honors in
secondary mathematics and so that's what
I trained to teach and I did teach that
for several years right now I'm still
classroom teaching but I also have a
bunch of other hats that I wear
so you mentioned I have one with the
University I love being the universe
education and that's enough 12 months
now that I've been able to do that I
also have within the New South Wales
Department of Education because I've
worked in public schools my whole
working life I get to work across the
state writing professionally for
teachers and it's super important that
we get into a place where we can lend
our capacity our leadership to others
and support them and I've certainly
realized after teaching for 12 years I'm
now kind of that next generation looking
at people coming through this university
and okay I have knowledge and expertise
to pass on to them as well but there is
a couple of them so the first ones who's
wonderful world of math so as you might
be able to tell about me the kind of
person who really enjoys like cheesy
names like I'm age my youtube channel
reach you is kind of like I have so many
of my ex students who are like I kind of
think it's like a bad joke it's like I
think it's bad but I'm gonna watch it
exactly right so said that was the first
book which over this last year and
partly because taking us tangent for a
second I hosted a children's TV series
for the ABC and a lot of the kids who
are watching that the quiet yard is
certainly younger than the high school
students that I teach so a lot of people
picked up that first ball compared to
say how old does my kid have to be to
read this book and I'd be like oh so the
second book is 80 blues magical maths
it's a children's activity I'm a big
believer that mathematics could be
accessible for everyone a lot of people
I think closed himself off from it me
like Mayor when I was at school was too
hard didn't understand all those X's and
Y's and weird graphs and that they head
out into life just sort of feeling like
that doors be closed forever
and I think that's true I think anyone
can pick that up later in life it's part
of my own story as well what would you
say to someone because I've definitely
fallen victim to something like oh no I
I'm an English person I'm not a math
person something like this so I'm going
to I guess my response to that would be
two things I suppose I would say the
first odds would be autobiographical so
when I was at school the kind of kid I
was was all about the humanities like I
did drama all the way through year 9 10
11 12 soon as I could choose it I took
it on I just loved the power of
storytelling English and history was the
same and so when I go to university I do
want it to be a teacher so I thought
well I'll become a humanities teacher
that was the plan now it sort of took a
radical left turn when I discovered
there's this huge need in mathematics
education and so I had to go down this
rabbit hole of learning maths almost
from scratch like I felt like you know
I'm sure people knew out there if I say
something like Pythagoras theorem like
that's some way to get around your grade
you're like he's a thing I've learned as
a young student how to do that but I
didn't understand anything about why it
mattered or what its significant was for
my life and so I kind of had to learn
all those things from scratch
and so I want to say anyone who feels
like they don't have a specimen neither
was I
maybe there's not such a thing as like
you're locked in and the second thing is
like there's a lot of research that
talks about neuroplasticity and the
amazing ability of the brain to rewire
itself and do things we thought were
previously impossible so I guess I would
say is never count yourself that it's
never too late so everyone can be a math
person 100% great perfect and so it's
interesting because through that whole
journey studied in arts and social
sciences to become a teacher how would
you describe that experience like what
you did on campus here it was a series
of wonderful surprises and shocks
usually did you know describe a shock as
a good thing but you know delightfully
surprised for example if you could
picture working your entire life of it
used to like climb a particular mountain
like Everest or something like that and
you've like maybe it's your life's goal
and you've prepared everything and then
you get to the top and you're like I've
reached the summit can you imagine what
it would feel like if you've reached the
summit and then from that vantage point
you suddenly realize oh there are like
there's the whole mountain range in the
distance that I couldn't see from the
ground but now that I'm here I realize
there's so much more to learn and that's
what university was like for me I think
many people who are contemplating like
Ito's over got my HSC you or my ib under
my belt I'm like cool oh my goodness
that's all behind me but you're about to
reach the top of a summit that will show
you this big wide world around you and
when I got to when I got to Sydney
the people are surrounded by my
lecturers and my tutors they're just
constantly would give me all these ideas
are never interacted with I go into my
professors office with a question I
wanted answer and then
but I had five more questions in my head
I didn't even know to ask for that and
I'm sure you've had that experience to
every single thing it's kind of like
that was a timid answer to a five second
question but now my brain is just all
the videos that so many things I think
is a five second answer and if you think
about it a little bit more it's actually
quite yeah it's that um that complexity
and nuance in the world that I
think you know so often we want well not
simple ways to understand things it's
not like searching for a simple
understanding is a bad thing but what
university I love pushed on was that
everything is different shades you need
to see it from all these different
perspectives and I think that was what
was great about coming to our school
where I think it was a fairly sheltered
environment I went to school with a lot
of people very similar to me and when I
went to uni I thought okay well lots of
people are gonna be like me they've
chosen the same degree so different and
brought such different perspectives
values priorities I was a real
eye-opening experience great no I I
could not agree more I also had a high
school experience that was a lot of
people it was a lot of very similar
people and so to come to somewhere like
the University of Sydney that just hosts
diversity in so many different ways was
really really oh my goodness we are
getting a lot of questions coming
through Wow okay question I got a really
high HR and want to become a teacher but
my family tells me I should do something
like law do you have any advice for how
I can convince my family to let me
become a teacher okay so that that
question that particular question like I
could have written 70 year old me
could have written that question because
as someone who sort of like I excelled
in languages in communication like law
was sort of what my parents exactly I
guess you know especially also coming
from a migrant background I was born
here like my siblings but my parents
definitely made a lot of sacrifices to
come here and know that this is not what
this is for like we didn't come here for
this reason so I I totally get like that
struggle is very real I guess you don't
say is number one in view of that don't
necessarily feel like convincing your
family is gonna be the be-all end-all
because you know what like I don't think
that it necessarily is productive to
pour all of your energy into something
which you may never be fully convinced
when I think about my own children and
you know even though I'm sure the person
asking these questions like 17 or 18
years old our parents will still think
of us as five and six years of their
we've lived our entire lives meeting
them their direction is support and it's
really hard I already know having
children who are in Priory school it's
hard to make that transition and so I
want to say look you're gonna be the
person who has to live with the
consequences of the choice that you make
for your life like you're the one just a
study Matt and I will say are we the
most helpful thing at least for my dad
right my mum passed away when I was in
first year so she never really got to
see all of what happened but what can
it's my dad I think was that he wanted
me to do something that I was good at
and made a difference in the world and
then I could really put my best efforts
toward yeah and I think that what I
started to do that as a student teacher
when I was volunteering and then when I
got into full-time work right at the
beginning I think that was what sealed
the deal and I know that's a very it's a
very long-term answer but I don't think
there is a I'd love to give you up this
is the thing you say and then it's but
it's uh it's you know the attitude that
makes your parents care so much that
they have that very particular desire
for you that's been years in the making
probably before you award so it's not
going to go away fast so I think what's
important is that there's a willingness
to come to a sort of agreement that yeah
it's okay we have different prize this
open to thinking about what law might
look like but I also feel very strongly
about education and no one's gonna make
a difference I think that will really
and it makes okay next question what did
you like most about Sydney the buildings
look really cool did you join any club
wow that's a tough question
yeah I agree
the buildings do look really cool I know
a lot of my students that I teach when
they come to Sydney and I also the next
day hey what did you think of it
they're like oMG it looks like Hogwarts
so like okay yeah what else okay it's
true also point out I mean I mentioned
if this building's new so many of the
buildings on campus now didn't exist
when I went through it's it's a
beautiful space and I think that
Sydney's really looking after its
students by giving them that I think
I liked most about Sydney being part of
a community of people who we touched on
this before you know have have got this
same goal we want to change and improve
education around the world
but go about in such different ways
challenge me to think about education in
a way that I've never contemplated
before and broaden my perspective on it
and then for them to be like 12 years
later after graduating I'm still in
touch with all these people they're
still amazing leaders in my field and in
other fields as well that I'm kind of
like my life is enriched and it's the
gift that keeps on giving for having
been part of this currently I guess the
last question oh it disappeared redeker
Oh clubs was I probably can't absolutely
was I can't recommend highly enough be
involved in the the life of the campus
in fact that is one of the best things
about three and if I even like I had the
choice in third year I think so like
cram everything into a small compressed
timetable then I could work more and
have a few days on campus and more time
away I thought to myself actually no
what I have some flexibility here and
don't mean come yeah I'll let us spend
more time on campus so that I can enjoy
that as party education society the edge
of the Union a bunch of other things and
those again those relationships and that
exposure to a wonderful network of
people that was really special amazing
ok I'm going to try to get through as
many questions as we can the next one is
was it hard to study maths for teaching
brackets
it's very sweet sure that's ah yes it
absolutely was I mean Matt is a tough
subject we human beings we evolved to be
good at language that's part of what it
means to be human we didn't evolve to be
good at understanding abstract
mathematics and it's part of why it's
also so powerful it looks like separates
us from the rest I kind of think in
those hard that was part of why it was
so valuable as a teacher now it's really
important that the longer I teach the
more familiar I get with these concepts
and I can sort of easily fall into that
idea of like why don't you understand
it's
so obvious to me and that's actually a
really terrible thing to say to a
student so that empathy of struggle and
being able to say I get it I know
exactly what that feels like I beat your
head against the wall I got that from
the difficulty of rigor all of the
mathematics I study absolutely okay
great
was there anything special you learned
at Sydney that has helped you to be such
a good teacher also that's just
compliments odeon oh yeah
thank you I okay so there are a lot of
pieces here I will first like half of an
answer go back to something I said
before be good anything but especially
being a good teacher requires the
continued input into your professional
life of knowledge and learning
challenging your ideas I remember
reading this some sociological bar from
the isolates the 80s or the 90s and
called the strength of weak ties which
is all about when you've got a
connection with someone maybe you don't
see that often maybe they live in the
u.s. maybe they're a distant connection
but it's because of the the weakness of
that time that this is somewhere far
away from me I don't see them often that
gives that relationship a particular
strength because that person by virtue
of their distance they know things and
they've experienced things that you will
never see and can challenge you in
thinking of learning so that is part of
that community that I mentioned before
but I think the other fear is just about
the primacy of relationship one of the
things I picked up at Sydney from the
people who told me to become a teacher
is that no one teaches a subject you
teach students right and in the
Australian professional standards for
teachers which is the document that
tells teachers like what is a great
teacher look like what is progression
look like in that profession the firsts
of the standards of which they're seven
it's not about knowing content - how to
teach it that's number two number one is
knowing students and how they learn and
that colours everything I do every
single day I hurt that's part of what
makes someone think tell a good teacher
oh great I want to be a teacher great
start I want to be a teacher but I'm
and then I wouldn't be good at it and
that the kids won't like me do you have
any advice sure
Wow okay well this is a very natural
concern to have I certainly felt that
many times particularly when you're a
student teacher at the beginning at uni
and then in your first couple of years
because you sort of still feel like a
very young person and you've got to
prove yourself and especially if you're
in high school you've got a you have to
earn the respect of these teenagers
right I did feel that a lot and I know
that one of the ways that I sort of you
moved forward from that is having a bit
of confidence in myself and the fact
that yeah okay I'm not gonna be I'm not
like I'm not the super trendy teacher
she's really good at sport or anything
like that but I have other parts that a
wonderful and are exactly what a
particular student needs that's actually
really important point in terms of being
liked we're not ever a student's friend
there's there's a there's a professional
distance that is important to maintain
there because when you're interacting
with the student when you're there to be
a buddy there are certain things that
you need to do as a teacher that are
impossible
like for example discipline them and
talk to them about the expectations you
have for them as a mentor as a guide and
not as a friend so being liked I think
comes a little bit from the fact that
understands bizarre but it comes from
not caring about whether you're light
but actually carry about whether you do
what's right - - and give them what they
want I'll give you a classic example
many many years ago I was actually I
taught him more than once but in the
first year or taking a tourist student
named him he was in my unite class and
Tim was a funny kid really great sense
of humor but as a consequence he
constantly caused me problems in class
because he was just exactly loved and I
would like tell him all from the class
and he would just love that even more
yes shower me with attention yeah and I
just like I was at wit's end I didn't
know how to deal with him in my class
right what I eventually went out to do
was look you know his behavior was
impacting the learning of everyone else
in the class and so I had to be pretty
strict with him and
hated me for it he was like mr. he would
he would you know he was yes yes totally
I'm cool and I I was convinced at the
end of the I was like well you know I
did my best I didn't do very well with
him much to my surprise years later
after graduating he he came to me he
visited school after he'd been working
for him and he said to me you know what
was the word you were the only teacher
who pulled me up Wow every other teacher
there like it seems funny and he's gonna
be like that but whatever just let him
do his thing you said something like
that that you knew I was capable of more
and that's why he was so strict in
harsher to me and I hated at the time
but I realized even though it wasn't
what I wanted it was what I needed and
you know what
for every Tim who came to me afterwards
years later and told me that there are
lots of them who did it but I know I had
that impact on students you've got to
know what they need and and so that
comes with a confidence that actually
ironically is likable I mean these
customers are they're talking about they
worth trusting and actually going with
even if they do things I don't always
enjoy absolutely well I hope you
continue to want to be a teacher
dear audience member going to get to one
more question what advice can you give
to future year 12 students about the HSC
Wow
so many well it is it is a big maybe
that's a good place to start it is a
mountain to climb and it takes a lot of
effort I guess my first piece of advice
is if you don't climb this mountain you
really need the help of people around
you and there's an old African proverb
that says if you want to go fast go
alone if you want to go far go together
and energy you know the educational
journey you go through towards your
agency and beyond that it's a marathon
like if you if you go out at football
you're just exhausted self and it's not
sustainable and actually is sadly I've
taught many students and they get to the
point of emotional breakdown as they get
to the end of year 12 the pressure just
gets too much so you've really got a
lien on those people around you and be
be collaborative in the way that you
work toward that goal the second thing
I'd say is know what really matters to
you and why
learning what you like if you're
learning stuff for like a lot of people
send me you didn't like Mass when you're
at school
what changed how did that transition and
for me it was a change in purpose I was
not nerdy maths just because I had to do
a test
I was letting rest because I need to be
able to stand up in front of students
and be genuine and authentic and
convince them that this is something
worth learning they gave me a whole
different outlook on why I was thinking
about this stuff and learning it that
outlook
I hope change like a sense of purpose I
think will change the way you say a last
piece of advice look after yourself take
care of the body and mind do it under
any circumstances like stop doing sport
if you love sport and you're like are
you 12 I better get serious now
now this horrible news day news for get
what you say it'll keep you healthy your
brain is part of your physical body you
want to be fit if you want to perform
your best and you've got to look after
yourself psychologically your well-being
a song point and so like a lot of people
will then will shortchange themselves on
sleeps and they can read more do or pass
papers and you're it's nothing is more
kind of productive than doing that so
look after yourself and you'll make it
to the end okay by the time I graduate
from teaching it will be so long do you
think that the future of teaching the
future of teaching work might change by
the time I finish compared to now I can
say with confidence that teaching will
change by the time someone finishes
their degree I've been teaching for 12
years and even though that that
relatively short amount of time compared
to like a teaching career there's been
significant changes in technology in
syllabus in this enormous social
experiment that we're conducting on you
know young people of today but everyone
in their dog has a smartphone and we
kind of have it attached to our hips and
that changes when we interact socially
that wasn't a thing when I started
teaching like you know the iframe was
only invented I've been teaching for a
couple of years so yes will change but
in some ways the parts of Education that
matter most won't change humans are
humans
humans of humans and if there's one
thing I've learned from teaching across
the country and around the world to that
even when there's language barriers and
differences in culture young people
still love to learn
they still love to have the experience
of discovery and surprise they still
love a challenge there's still people
who need to be cared for and supported
and guided through the difficult
emotional you know ups and downs of
their lives these things are timeless
and so whatever preparation you get yes
there will be lifelong learning and
adaptation but that's okay it's part of
the fun of being a lifelong learner
great so they don't have to worry about
their degree becoming kind of outdated
or it's still going to be relevant if
there's anything that an educator knows
it's that having that commitment to
continue growing and learning is what
really matters but what's great about
what I learned at uni is that it gave me
a foundation for how to think and
approach all those new things I was
gonna learn it gave me a framework to
fit that into and so you know sure the
syllabus will be different that's
syllabus that you learn to teach when
you uni yeah it's gonna shift and change
but also it's going to give you an
avenue and a sort of platform to learn
those new things and understand okay
great um we are going to have to wrap
but last advice what would you offer
current students that are thinking about
coming to study I want to say this is an
amazing place to be and I kind of look
back I spent four amazing years here and
one of my biggest regrets is that I
could spend more it went by so fast and
the the relationships and the the new
ideas and the community that I became
part of they've informed who I am in
many ways to find my character if I've
not come here I wouldn't have been
challenged to say teach mathematics -
English in history and that's literally
like everything that anyone knows before
has to do with that defining change that
was given to me I was challenged to make
when I came here to Sydney University so
I'm excited for anyone who's
contemplating me here it's a it's an
even better place now
and I was here it's really actually
despite being Australia's oldest
University it's one of the most
progressive I think so it's an exciting
place to be in 2020 and beyond
I completely agree thank you so much for
speaking with us in wonderful and
speaking with you we're about to go to a
short break but if you have any
questions this will be our last segment
so get those questions in quick and I
will do my best to answer them for you
thank you my pleasure I see you guys